kristen
chanello i heard you're wearing all
chanel
we have to say we have to incorporate it
into everything because not only do you
look amazing but your wonderful director
was just telling me about how chanel
custom made that outfit for you for the
movie how amazing was that
it's my it's my favorite look in the
movie and it's hard to say something
like that because it is it is just
top to bottom a very very beautiful
costume film but
this is like chanel couture
deconstructed to the max like
diana doesn't actually end up at the
dinner she's supposed to go to in that
dress she ends up in the in the bathroom
in a bit of a heap so um
yeah it's meaningful very i love it's so
beautiful it's still it's still not able
to hold her up you also of course wear
the iconic wedding dress look and he
said it was very close to the original
what was it like for you to put that on
which had to i would imagine feel like
taking something on
um
when we put that dress on it is uh
embedded in a montage that kind of
flashes her life before you even though
the movie takes place over a three-day
period
and so even though i play her as a
you know speculatively 29 20 or 29 30
year old person we still wanted to kind
of give a taste of the scope of her life
kind of touch on every part even if it
was in a kind of lyrical dance and the
wedding dress is embedded in that
montage and putting that on was a spooky
day
yeah we didn't have to do the wedding
scene but we still i mean i still had
one walk
walking
outside of this castle he was just sort
of like you know i was like wait but
this is so particular this actually does
land on a very precise day of her life
and he's like take everything you
learned about that day all of your
emotional responses that you have
accumulated
put them all right here what does it
feel like to believe in a in an ideal
that then becomes
very very apparently farcical and
it's kind of just like let your heart
break in a moment i was like okay got it
let's go let's run what is it i was
about to say what does it feel like and
then you hit me with let your heart
break
um i am a little blinded by the necklace
how many carrots are we wearing is there
security with that tonight i'm supposed
to give this back soon yeah are you
before i leave this location
yeah i like it too
um also wanted to ask about the the
diner scene she walks in and there's
this moment if she's recognized
everyone's staring at her how did it
feel to do that and do you remember when
maybe you had that first moment
um yeah i mean she walks into this diner
just to get some directions
and also it's a little bit silly i mean
you would imagine there's there's an
absurdist kind of nature to that scene
because you're like dude you are
princess diana you just walked into a
fish and chip shop like clearly you know
people are going to have this reaction
but i think she's kind of entering
an experience that she doesn't she has
such a reticence to go back to the house
for christmas that she'll just go
anywhere else it's like when you're late
for an appointment you're like i'm 20
minutes late i can't find my keys it's
like can you not find your case or do
you not want to go to that appointment
um so i kind of was like walking in
there being like does anyone else want
to hang out because this sucks
the royal family might see this members
of it they've watched the crown what do
you hope they take away from it if
anything if they want to spend their
time indulging their own curiosities
about ours i would say that we led with
love and and the only reason we made
this movie is because
that person
that we will never be able to know is
somebody that influenced us intimately
and and we're still talking about her i
think that i think the
very
literal legacy that she left behind in
her boys are
you know for me as somebody who
attempted to dream about her and her
life and imagine what her life must have
felt like in a way that is is not even
remotely an authority this is too
personal being somebody that played
diana she would be so proud i mean all i
would say is like we led with love and
curiosity and and and profess to know
nothing we're literally just sort of
admirers congrats on the oscars buzz
thank you
feel okay it feels more than better than
okay like very okay
you